here in Mali german army trainers are
coaching a practice session in
house-to-house combat elvex ooh so meta
haha so good no long oh I'll be there
Wow boom this soldier says he likes the
sound of the explosion he's an engineer
and proud to be working with the Germans
and ma chef Deborah an element is Ginny
that's why some kid who knows to do
pânico don't let me there I'm in cuckoo
rule 60 kilometers from Molly's capital
Bamako Germany's Bundys fair is training
Molly's army as it prepares to go up
against Warrick rebels in the north of
the country
carsten a curt is in command of the
german contingent fuels over PSV says
the climate here in western Africa is
hard to deal with the temperatures can
hit 50 degrees and in the rainy season
it's muggy soldiers can only train for a
few hours before they need a break he
says the weather affects the mullions
the same way plus there are snakes
spiders and malaria to contend with
Lords on V I'm not really here mr. Yosh
Lang spin on to filing that yarder
Mulally at sack em from the camp in
coolly Carew is part of an EU mission
armies from 22 European countries are
represented Germany sent 100 personnel
the real mission starts in three weeks
the mullions will be deployed to the
north where they'll experience desert
combat it'll be a challenge for everyone
here physically I take the German
commander says Europeans are used to of
my tech weaponry and equipment he adds
the Malian army has everything it needs
for the mission but some material is
much more basic than what the Europeans
work with it poses a challenge for the
trainers I'm in de dust like it's you to
awaken of a midori I vomited if this
were a real live combat situation there
would likely be casualties in this case
the Mali and Commander simply interrupts
the exercise his recruits still lack
basic reflexes crucial to their survival
through my not better he says everyone's
afraid that you have to face your fear
and conquer it for the honour and
liberty of the country doc is it well
that's why he volunteered to go to the
North was to help save the nation he
didn't biella
the individual see general d da da co
was in charge of troops in the north
when heavily armed warrick rebels
launched an offensive executing entire
Garrison's he watched helplessly as his
soldiers deserted one after another my
dad his mom he says they left quite a
bit of military hardware behind on the
battlefield so they first had to rebuild
their armament stocks before they could
concentrate on other things so steadily
ovando sketchy after caucuses well as
part of the UN military mission
Germany's bundes fair is helping to
transport food equipment and personnel
to the north ottoville bers is in charge
of the German air mission here he told
me overland transport is too dangerous
and all civilian flights have been
grounded
bamako Airport is a true clash of
cultures the loading process is a lot
more hectic than it would be in Germany
the mullions have no idea how heavy this
palette is so the German soldiers help
out 440 kilograms on the right 440 on
the left almost a ton
finally the German loading supervisor
can determine how many passengers can
ride along in the transport plane
tomorrow they're heading to gaol and
then further north to the Algerian
border region I asked how dangerous it
is there the gods of British me enough
God is hot air commander bieber's says
it's not as serious as Afghanistan but
throughout the North in their operating
area there are incidents and some are
fatal the journey begins at 5am final
preparations then the plane is cleared
for takeoff
the loadmaster also acts as steward
reminding passengers of safety
procedures
I feel queasy I'm the only woman on
board some of the men are wearing
bulletproof vests
it's my first flight in a plane like
this
the belt doesn't stabilize me much
shortly after starting the g-force
pushes me on to my neighbor we fly along
the niger river past cooley kuru and
after two hours we reach cow it's calm
here but the loadmaster has his own
concerns he says there will be problems
with the heavy loads because there's no
forklift there probably are none around
if by some chance there is one it'll
belong to the French Army and the French
aren't part of the UN mission today's
offloading challenge is a metal gun
locker weighing 500 kilograms the
loadmaster says everything is supposed
to be registered but the information
isn't always passed on to him 45 minutes
later the frustration is growing the gun
locker is still in place eventually the
pilot is fed up he goes off to talk to
the head of the French mission within
minutes everything is straightened out
I'm amazed at how jealously the French
and the UN soldiers defend their turf
with petty squabbles like this over
trivial matters
we fly on towards the Algerian border
region a rough landing on the dirt
runway and Tessalit the propeller is
damaged after taking a hit from a rock
I'm ordered to stay in the plane until
the airfield is secured the UN has
deployed soldiers from Chad here it's
difficult to tell the various
international contingent apart the
nervousness is palpable the area came
under attack last week one thousand
kilometers further south the mood is
much different as we take a walking tour
the German soldiers visit Tian Tian
boogoo a village near the training camp
the German soldiers have prepared well
for this visit a translator is coming
along and they have brought a half sack
of rice for the village elders the
children receive gummy bears the
visitors are welcomed the soldiers also
present the villagers with the schedule
of the next training sessions it's
important that the locals move their
livestock before the explosions begin
again a smart odds torsten a Kurt the
German commander says the detonations
are deafening he has to warn the people
so they're not frightened or surprised
on the other hand he must make it clear
that the Bundeswehr soldiers are
performing an important task yeah I
invite like that's a license as you know
either army the training will help the
Malian army secure regions in the north
the sight of white people causes quite a
sensation in the village everyone is
curious and wants to talk to the
soldiers this man says the explosions
don't bother him if he hears a bang he
knows it's a training exercise for Molly
soldiers and that makes him happy
this woman says she's glad the Germans
are here because they're helping back at
the training camp the Germans are
engaged in an exercise to me it seems
like the soldiers take forever to come
to the aid of their injured comrades but
that's also part of the training
personal safety comes first this
exercise is finished the soldiers have
spent seven weeks in the camp their
crackling with energy and
self-confidence I drive to the capital
Bamako it's my fourth trip here but this
time everything is different the
international military presence has
changed things food prices are up milk
is a luxury in Africa but this vendor
tells me it's even more expensive now
downtown the UN has taken over one of
the best hotels transforming it into
Mission headquarters they have their own
safety standards and rules it's a world
unto itself
in the evening I mitla means who say he
offers consulting services for
foreigners in Mali and organizes
seminars like everyone I've met here
he's grateful for the international aid
but he also sees a downside lacaze my
inclusive he says it's nearly impossible
to rent a car in Bamako because the UN
troops and other military trainers pay
prices far beyond what the locals can
afford there are other knock-on effects
to housing prices are up because
thousands of additional people need
lodging and wherever the UN troops go
lots of babies are born afterwards poco
de pelea de Mille air parcel allergy
conceivably back to hooli the first lien
a surgeon is impossible is a bucket on
phone despite these problems the
mullions are optimistic they swear that
within two years everything will be back
to normal